this video will explain the story of
Final Fantasy XV not only will we be
talking about Clive's Journey but we'll
also be discussing the ending and what
it could mean for the future of the
series as always think of your
screenings for providing me a code early
so I could have some time to dissect its
narrative also if you like some
informative videos like this one feel
free to check out my other videos on
other games like Horizon forbidden West
Elden ring and God of War Ragnarok if
you're interested in some story analysis
on top of that though feel free to check
out the rest of my catalog where we
discuss a game story of also critiquing
its narrative along the way and lastly
spoiler warning ahead I'll be spoiling
all the events of the story and we'll
also be talking about some late game
moments very early on in the video so
please finish the game and come back
with that out of the way though let's
get started
so before we delve into the meat of this
thing I want to make it clear for the
new fans of the series that you don't
need to understand the previous games in
order to play this one all the Final
Fantasy games are independent of one
another save for a few titles with
dashes or additions in their name like
Final Fantasy 10 and its sequel 10-2
while the games do have constant
reoccurring characters like chocobos
mughals and the summons it's mostly just
Final Fantasy stuff and has no
connection to the previous gains outside
of that on top of that though I also
want to take some time to talk about the
world of this game usually this kind of
thing is only important to those who
want all the Nitty Gritty details which
is why it's in the Codex but a lot of
16's plots hinge on the relationship
between its kingdoms and the state of
the world so to begin the world of Final
Fantasy is called valessia there are
also two known continents within it
called storm and Ash storm is where we
are for the majority of the game with
Ashby in the last location we visit in
the main story by saying known though
because there seems to be more
continents outside of these two as both
Sid and Barnabas came to these lands
from somewhere else but the game only
talks about these two in this world is a
variety of Kingdoms to the Northwest is
the duchy of Rosaria home to Cloud and
his family to the West is the iron
Kingdom a brutish clan of Warriors who
are the ones that took Jill early on in
the game in the south is the dalmekian
Republic whose dominant is the Titan
Hugo Kuka in the Northeast is the holy
Empire of sambrik a Royal Kingdom Under
the rule of the emperor whose son Dion
is the dominant of Bahamut and finally
in the Southeast is the kingdom of welud
the only Kingdom left in the continent
thanks to the blight whose ruler is King
Barnabas a dominant in control of Odin
throughout this section I've said the
word dominant a lot these are
individuals who have the power to wield
icons ferocious beasts that have
unimaginable amounts of power despite
how ass backwards this is though having
magic in the world of Final Fantasy XV
makes people look at you as less than
human magic and valessia is generated
from The Ether the essence of the world
the mother crystals are the source of
the crystals that people use for a
variety of things like lighting lamps or
lighting their smoke the world has
become so dependent on them that without
magic the world might delve into chaos
thankfully bears exist who are humans
that can cast magic without needing a
crystal that's why they're used as
slaves as king Villages use them for
their magical needs they're also branded
by a mark on their cheeks that people
know that they are bearers the dominants
are fortunately treated less poorly but
it all depends on where they're from
some like Dion and Joshua are seen as
royalty in a Beacon of Hope for the
lands that they're in but others like
the iron Kingdom has taken to enslaving
their dominance and abusing their power
there is still an underlying problem
though and that's the magic itself as
this either has to come from somewhere
which is what leads us to the blight the
blight is this blackish well blight that
destroys anything it touches and the
more magic the people use the more the
land is consumed by this blight which
would start the entire plot of the game
as Sid believes that the mother crystals
are to blame for this this is the basic
structure of Valencia there is still a
lot more to discuss but we'll get to
that in due time I just wanted to cover
this part now so you can understand why
the world is the way that it is
beginning with the main story we start
with our main character Clive in the
year 860. there are a few scenes before
this but we'll come back to them during
the story anyway Clive is currently
training so he could become a proper
first shield Rosaria is the owner of the
icon the Phoenix and given that the
rossfield family has taken great strides
to ensure the Phoenix stays in the
bloodline Clive was set to be the next
dominant of the Phoenix but it skipped
him and went to his brother Joshua now
we know why Clive was skipped as he has
his own powers but at the time no one
knows why which is why some consider him
the firstborn failure within his family
are his siblings Jill and Josh and his
parents Arc Duke ellwin and Empress
Annabella now Jill isn't actually his
sister but he's always treated her like
one Joe is a princess from the Northern
Territories but since that land was
overcome with blight they needed a new
place to live which is when Elwyn took
them in and made Jill a ward so while
she's not a part of the royal family
she's always been around them for years
which is how she came to know the
rossfield brothers while Elwyn loves his
children unconditionally though the same
cannot be said for Annabella she
believes it's her duty to continue the
bloodline to keep the Phoenix in their
bloodline which is why she married elwin
who is funny enough her cousin she loves
Joshua though but doesn't care about
Clive too much due to the whole
firstborn failure thing since Clive
didn't get to Phoenix he decided that
the next best thing to do would be to
become a first shield which is basically
The Bodyguard of the Phoenix his entire
purpose is now to make sure Joshua lives
which isn't too hard given that they're
siblings so he would have done that
anyway Clive then goes to his father's
quarters as he has a mission for him
Rosaria plans to take the fight to the
iron Kingdom as they have control of the
mother Crystal Drake's breath and they
need its power so they could fight back
against the blight which is hilarious
given that that's the thing that's
causing the blight but no one knows that
yet while that happens Clive is to
handle some reports about goblins nearby
and then head to Phoenix gate once he's
done this gate is a holy place for
Rosaria as according to the legend there
is a door only accessible to the Phoenix
that allows them to hear the thoughts of
their previous users this doesn't seem
to be true though as these Gates belong
to the fallen and ancient race of beings
who have long since passed not much is
known about them sadly but their
structures still remain regardless this
is Clive's first emission so it's
important that he succeeds feeds but
just in case he's also given two men to
help him sir Wade and Sir Tyler once
they finish up and arrive at the gate
the men cheer and celebrate as they talk
about Clive's battle with the marble as
they all head to bed the guards discover
that they've been attacked by the holy
Empire of Sam brick this doesn't seem to
be a normal attack though as they seemed
to know exactly where the group was
that's because Annabella betrayed
Rosaria as she determined that Sam brick
were the more powerful Kingdom and
decided to strike a deal with them
Sandra gets the new land of Rosaria and
Annabelle gets worn into the royal
family thus becoming the Empress of Sam
brick while attempting to defend the
game from Invaders elwin is killed in
front of Joshua who ends up activating
his Phoenix powers in order to defend
his people Clive attempts to help Joshua
before being overcome by some raging
force of power which activates his icon
Ifrit this is literally impossible as
not only are there only eight icons but
there is only one of each so having a
ninth icon who is also a second icon of
fire is unheard of Joshua also has no
idea who this icon is and Clive can't
control it so Joshua has to defeat Ifrit
or he'll die sadly Clive ends up winning
and kills his brother although from his
perspective he believes that someone
else killed him Clive then transforms
back into a human and is then taken by
the Sam brick Army to become a bearer
this then leads us to the present day
where Clive and his new group are tasked
with killing the dominant Shiva now that
he's a bear he's forced to do with the
Holy Empire tells him to do or be put to
death otherwise currently the iron
Kingdom and The dalmekian Republic are
fighting a war and Clive and Company are
being sent in as a third party to kill
the Shiva dominant once they find her
though Clive realized that the dominant
is Jill after the attack on Phoenix gate
she was taken by the iron Kingdom who
decided to make a move on Rosaria now
that it was weakened and in doing so
they took a lot of people including Jill
this is when she would awaken her powers
and realize that she was the dominant of
Shiva Clive obviously refused to kill
her which leads to a fight with some of
the group before being ambushed by more
men of the iron Kingdom before they kill
him though he is saved by a man named
Sid who not only has their old dog
torgel with him but he's also the
dominant of Rama Sid used to be a part
of the kingdom of willud before he
eventually left the kingdom and started
his own place called Sid's Hideaway this
place is for dominance and bears alike
to live out the rest of their lives in
safety due to how the rest of the world
treats them he was originally here to
get Jill but he also took Clive with him
seeing as he's now currently a bear once
he arrives Clive talks the city about
killing the man who killed Joshua during
the attack there was a hooded man who
appeared and Clive assumes that he was
Joshua's killer going off some later
dialogue it seems like Clive knew that
he killed Joshua but was so traumatized
by the experience that he had it buried
deep in his mind and convince himself
that someone else did it that's why he
wants to find this man and Sid might be
able to help him as a second dominant of
fire was spotted nearby in a remote
Village the man seems to have
disappeared though as the only person of
note here is benedicta someone from the
kingdom of walude and the dominant of
Garuda the two will end up fighting for
a bit but after this we see a cutscene
of benedicta torturing the hooded man
the thing is though is that this is
Joshua the hooded man we saw at the
beginning of the game is kind of a red
herring as Clive assumes that this is
the second dominant to Fire Plus Joshua
also wears a hooded robe this man is
neither of these things as this is
Ultima Ultima is a Godlike entity will
talk about later but seeing as he needs
Clive to complete his objective it makes
sense why he's appearing to watch over
him Clive assumes that this person
killed Joshua when we know it was clived
the whole time and this rumor about a
second dominant of fire being seen at
the Village was likely just Joshua
seeing as he's being kept prisoner by
benedicta plus yote is also next to him
who we know protects Joshua with her
life further confirming that this is
Joshua and that the hooded man is just
Ultima watching over Clive sitting Clive
then appeared to fight benedicta as she
is holding this supposed second dominant
to fire hostage during this time we
start to see some scenes of benedicta
and Barnabas one thing I'm still
personally confused about is benedicta
herself as she seems to like Sid
Barnabas and Hugo it's possible that
she's just sleeping with whoever's in
power but maybe she also likes them
while Hugo and Barnabas are hard to
pinpoint it seems pretty clear that she
likes Sid at one point but felt betrayed
at Sid's own betrayal when he decided to
leave willuden live on his own Sid was
the Lord commander of willoud so his
betrayal was quite a heavy blow to their
forces which is likely why Barnabas
created a harbard to replace him still
it seems like Sid and benedicta used to
have talks about leaving willud and
being free and while Sid upheld his plan
it seems like benedicte didn't and
decided to stay under the rule of walude
and Barnabas this message of servitude
vs Free Will and being able to make your
own choices regardless of if they're
right or wrong is a core part of this
game and this is just one of the many
references to it Sid wants dominance and
bears to be free and not be used by
those that would exploit them and while
Benedictus seemed to agree she felt that
it was her Duty to server Loot and also
her Duty as dominant to follow
barnabas's orders while she may not be
as bad as a bearer You could argue that
she is just like them as she is a slave
to her Masters benedicta is too far gone
to listen to reason so Clive and Sid
have to fight her but once she's
defeated Clive ends up taking some of
her powers by accident Clive may not
have the power of the Phoenix but he has
the ability to not only conjure Ifrit
but also take the powers of other
dominance and use them now it doesn't
seem to steal them completely nor can
Clive transform into them as he's never
become anything but if her throughout
the rest of the game and some of the
dominance like benedicta are still able
to fully Prime despite having their
powers taken it's a concept that is not
fully understood but it seems to differ
from person to person as Hugo doesn't
seem to be able to become Titan anymore
after Clive takes it but Dion could
still become Bahamut either way after
killing benedicta for real this time
Clive finally realized that he was the
icon that killed his brother and that
the person he was chasing all this time
was himself Sid also goes over to
benedicta and gives her a charm the two
likely shared Sid did care for her
regardless of their circumstances in his
sadness see that he couldn't save her
from her fate we then Circle back to
Clive who was in prison possibly for
lashing out due to him discovered that
he killed his brother Sid doesn't hold
it against him though and lets him out
once he's stable this whole ordeal is
quite the predicament for Clive as he's
only stayed alive so he could kill
Joshua's killer but now that he's
realized who it was he no longer has a
purpose in life anymore Sid still has
some work for him though as he's been
having a man named gav search for the
second dominant to fire just to remind
you once again Clive originally believed
that the hooded man was not only the
second dominant to fire but also
Joshua's killer the killer of Joshua was
obviously Clive as we just learned but
that second dominant to fire is Joshua
because at the time Clive still thinks
he's dead the hooded man who his Ultima
has nothing to do with Joshua dying nor
being the second dominant of fire but
Clive doesn't know that he'll then come
back to the Hideaway and get a chance to
talk to the greatest character in the
game nectar in all seriousness he's
actually here to see Jill now that she
is awake the two talk for and are
very happy to see each other as it's
been 13 years since the attack on
Phoenix gate and both of them assume the
other was dead Jill then becomes a part
of the party along with torgle and ends
up traveling to Martha's rest Martha's
Quest was made to show the player the
harsh reality of bears by having the
citizens speak to Clive as if he was a
slave and having him listen in on a
conversation between a recent mother and
her friends that talks about her new
baby being a bear and how she wants
nothing to do with it the mother doesn't
even consider the baby her child anymore
because it can use magic he'll also
explore the nearby Abby said he could
see the gruesome Fates that await all
bearers using magic enough times caused
their hands to become gray and Rocky
these seem to spread all across their
bodies until they shut down and die and
seeing his bears are only used for their
magical prowess their Fates are pretty
much sealed from the beginning
after Martha's rest both Clive and Joe
will travel to Phoenix gates in order to
find out the truth of what happened
there once they arrived they will enter
the structure that Joshua was supposed
to enter all those years ago inside is a
mural of some kind along with Ultima who
is still dressed as he hooded man from
before when he Reveals His Face though
it's shown to be Clive now this isn't
some Grand twist that Clive is the bad
guy or anything as Ultima is known to
transform into other people like how we
change from Benedict to Hugo when
talking with Barnabas way later in the
game Clive then goes into his mind and
attempts to defeat Ifrit what he's
basically doing is Conquering effort by
fighting him when Clive achieves his
limit break it says accept the truth
which means Clive is not only aware of
the fact that he killed Joshua but that
it's his sin to Bear he's no longer
running away from it anymore and
recognize that it's a part of him now
following this Clive and Joe will then
head back home to The Hideaway while we
see the Hugo's getting a box of
benedicta inside it's never stated or
shown what's in the box but seeing as
Hugo says that her body was defiled I'm
assuming it's either her head or some
body part this is puzzling for a few
reasons as apparently the person who
delivered it to him was Sid but that
doesn't make any sense seeing his
benedicta's body was clearly intact
after she died plus of all people Sid
would not dismember her and deliver it
to Hugo so clearly someone is setting
them up unless I'm mistaken I don't
recall this ever being brought up again
so it's ever confirmed who actually did
this my guess though is it's either
Ultima or Barnabas as we learn later
Barnabas served Ultima so the two have a
similar goal and I'm assuming that this
was used as a way to get Hugo to fight
Clive so he could claim another
dominant's power as he needs all of them
in order for Ultima to fulfill his plan
while this happens the Emperor of Sam
brick wants to expand his Empire so he
plans to take down the crystalline
Dominion this is one of the few Nations
I didn't talk about earlier as their
role isn't widely known the first time
we hear of them is right now and we
don't learn much about them because the
emperor is going to take it over by the
time we visit the nation the emperor
taking this over though is a problem as
all the other nations filed peace
treaties with the kingdoms that it could
be left out of any wars they fight due
to them not owning a dominant the
emperor seems to be breaking this treaty
which is going to cause some problems
for the rest of the world once the two
return back Sid it has a conversation
with them and this is when Sid tells
them that the mother crystals are things
that are causing the blight that engulfs
valessia sidiga word that the Emperor of
Sandberg would be moving his soldiers
out of the Nations that they could fight
so now would be a perfect time for them
to sneak into the kingdom and announce
and destroy the mother Crystal Sid wants
to create a better world and destroying
the crystals is the first step in doing
that seeing as they are currently
killing the world as we speak once they
make it inside the kingdom they see that
the minds have been overflooded with
ether either is usually a harmless
substance but too much of it in a
concentrated area can have harmful
effects on an individual as it turns
them akashic which are these mindless
creatures we see throughout the mines
dominance embarrassing to be resistant
to its effects though given that they
can Channel magic naturally without the
need of crystals so the party can enter
without issue the trio approaches the
crystal But realize that the core of the
mother crystal is quite difficult to
penetrate so Sid primes into Rama and
destroys it with his lightning staff as
a result though something appears out of
a portal next to the crystal called
Typhon this creature sadly never gets
mentioned again outside of this but
going off some late game conversations
this seems to be one of ultima's
Brothers defending the crystal Ultima
will tell us much later that some of his
kind were used to create the crystals
and keep them working so it's only
natural that they are also the Defenders
of it too regardless once Clive defeats
it Ultima arrives to take him before Sid
stops him Ultima also calls him Mythos
which is the name Ultima gave to the
person that would become his vessel with
Ultima repelled for now though the crew
is safe except the damage it took is
unrepairable and he's going to die it's
here where he realized that Clive's idea
was right Hideaway shouldn't be a place
for Bears to die in peace but rather a
place for them to live in peace Sid's
way of thinking was yeah well life
started off pretty bad but let's end
down a good note whereas Clive saw it as
the birth of a new life one that's not
under anyone's control it's a more
positive outlook on the situation and
it's what changed Sid's thinking as he
dies though he tells Clive to keep going
and to rid the world of the crystals
that the world can survive that's why
Clive takes on the name Sid after this
as his name being known as an outlaw
with something Sid wanted plus it's also
become a title now said the outlaw is no
longer a person but a title given to
those who uphold the same ideals as the
original Sid and that's what Clive is
going to do for now
before they can leave though Ultima
comes back to defeat them before Joshua
arrives to seal him inside his body
there's another confusing plot as
sealing Ultima didn't really do anything
seeing his Ultima still exist but there
is also an Ultima in Joshua's body which
we saw at the end of the game so once
again it's my thinking that this is a
brother of Ultima ultima's people all
share one Consciousness so realistically
they are all Ultima if that makes sense
that's why they all have the same name
and design as their under one mind this
is also likely why Ultima uses we
instead of i as he's referring to his
other Brethren as well regardless torgle
Clive and Jill leave while Joshua seals
an Ultima inside him while that happens
not only is the mother Crystal
disappearing but the Hideaway is being
attacked by the dalmekians at the order
of Hugo thanks to Sid apparently killing
benedicta pretty much everyone has been
slaughtered but we don't see the end
result yet as the game then skips five
years in the future we can see that
Clive and Jill are deep in the dalmekian
territory the fate of the Hideaway is
unknown for now but we will eventually
go to the new Hideaway and see that most
if not all the main members have lived
like gav Goods lady Care on and many
others Clive is also known as Sid the
outlaw meaning that not only is he the
new leader of the new Hideaway but that
Sid is now known across Valencia as the
person who destroyed the Sam brick
mother Crystal Clive is here to continue
the work of Sid by rescuing some bears
but they don't seem too excited about it
Sid told Clive they're reading the world
of the mother crystals is likely going
to make things worse before it gets
better and this is an example of that
Clive gave Bears a bad name so a lot of
them are being treated more harshly plus
anywhere that Clive is destruction is
soon to follow it really weighs on him
and makes him question of what he's
doing is right once he returns The
Hideaway Vivian his new advisor tells
him what occurred in the past few years
with the only notable piece of
information being that the Emperor of
sandbrick did indeed take over the
crystalline Dominion the next thing
Clive is tasked with doing is going back
to Martha's as some of her bearers have
been taken and killed this is because
Empress Annabella has ordered her Black
Knights to kill any impurities in the
Rosaria area and by that she means any
bears we can already see the her Knights
have made quick work of most of the land
as they've killed tortured and hung
various Bears already along the way they
will also come across sir Wade and also
Clive's Uncle who was the person they
came to meet in the first place as he
has lots of money and a few ships that
they plan to use as their next plan is
to go to the iron Kingdom and destroy
their mother Crystal taking down the
iron Kingdom's crystal is going to be
difficult for Jill at least Phoenix gate
forced Clive to relive his test and this
excursion is going to force Jill to do
the same she's had a pretty miserable
life there and witnessed things no one
should ever see so doing this is not
only going to be very difficult for her
but should also cleanse her of the pain
that she's had for years assuming they
succeed this also deepens the
relationship the two have as Joe was
there to help Clive relive his past and
now Clive is going to do the same for
Jill thankfully they do end up
succeeding as they make it inside the
kingdom and destroy the crystal they
also defeat this being called the liquid
flame which is likely another one of the
Crystal's defense mechanisms Joe will
also killed the leader of the church
here who is the one that made her do all
the Unspeakable things she doesn't wish
to talk about during her time here while
the group leaves we see Hugo talking to
some of the members of the dalmekian
council they want to lay claims to the
crystalline Dominion but they're
struggling to take it over Hugo could
help but using Titan would mean that
Dion would arrive and use Bahamut and
while one of them would eventually win
the Dominion would likely be destroyed
before that even happened so it would be
pointless that's why Hugo has come up
with another plan that involves Empress
Annabella the dalmekian Republic and the
holy Empire of Sandberg have been
fighting for quite some time so the two
decided to strike a deal so they could
stop the unnecessary Bloodshed the
empress is to allow Hugo to kill her son
if she does that all meccans will stop
their Siege Hugo realized that after
attacking the Hideaway Sid wasn't there
so now he's determined to find and kill
him technically he won't find Sid since
he's dead but Clive is not only the new
Sid but is also the person who actually
killed her so it works out anyway
sitting next to her though is her new
son Olivier who she claims to be the new
ruler of Sam brick soon surely after
this is when Hugo and his private guard
away to rosalith the same place we
started the game in an attempt to lure
Clive to him it's very clearly a trap
but Clive's gonna go anyway because he
doesn't want to let him destroy his home
as expected though Hugo is one step
ahead of him and captures both Clive and
Jill thankfully gev who might actually
be the best supporting cast member in
this game comes who had to break him out
of his cell Jill is about to be executed
and would have been had it not been for
torgel activating some kind of ability
and using it to take down the people
around her torgle is a frost wolf from
the Northern Territories and according
to the legend a frost wolf was also the
animal that accompanied the original
Shiva dominant and years ago which is
likely why Jill and torgel get along so
well they will then stay behind and
defend the door while Clive goes and
deals with Hugo who is partially primed
during the fight Clive is able to defeat
him by cutting his hands off but before
he can deliver the killing blow someone
comes by to take him this is learned to
be harbard from the kingdom of willude
now that Hugo's gone though the team
goes back to the Hideaway in order to
figure out who and where they took Hugo
as Clive needs to strike now that he's
weak this is where he learns that it was
walude who took them and the team
assumes that they took him back to the
dalmekian crystals that he may rest and
gain his powers back around this time
Clive will have a quick chat with mid
who happens to be Sid's daughter just
like her father she is eager to get
working on things but she needs Clive's
help to set up a workshop here so that
she can get started after that's done
Clive sets off to dalmekia to defeat
Hugo and upon entering the castle we see
that Hugo is talking to benedicta but
she doesn't seem to be there this is
likely Ultima influencing Hugo by making
him do what he wants which is to make
Hugo fight clubs that he may take his
powers again what follows is a very long
boss fight that sees the two fight with
icons and even though Hugo literally
eats a crystal to gain even more power
Clive is able to defeat him and take the
power of the Titan while also destroying
the Kingdom's mother Crystal also mobile
combine after the fight to talk to Clive
and tell him that he has to serve the
role he was made for Clive rejects this
which is what leads Ultima to determine
that he's going to need to sever the
consciousness of the Mind in order to
get Clive to obey simply put if he won't
come willingly Ultima is going to force
him to obey by breaking him after this
we get a few more cutscenes one of which
is between Harvard and Barnabas most of
it is irrelevant except the fact that
they both use the word muthos implying
that they know of Ultima and his plan
ends following this is a conversation
with Dion and his lover Terence who are
interrupted by one of his men who has a
note for him which states that Olivier
the new son of Annabella has taken the
role of Emperor from Dion the original
Emperor is fine with giving it up to his
new son as he's going to be advising him
until he's ready but the next in line
was supposed to be Dion naturally he's
pissed at the news but he's got more
coming to him as Joshua arrived shortly
after Joshua and Dion used to be friends
for a time so Dion recognized that this
is important as the dominant of the
Phoenix wouldn't just stroll into their
Camp just to lie to him Joshua then
tells Diana about ultiman how he planned
to take over the world this Sparks
something in Dion's mind as he wonders
if it was Ultima influencing the Emperor
as his recent Conquest like the attack
on the Dominion have been very
uncharacteristic of him Joshua came here
to hopefully recruit Dion to his cause
but he has duties of his own to do as
the dominant of Bahamut but his loyalty
to the kingdom seems to be wavering
thanks to Olivier and Annabella while
that happens the crew of Hideaway is
forced to do mids bidding as she wants
to make a ship called the Enterprise
that she needs supplies the problem is
that she plans to make it with mithril
engines which has been unheard of as of
now it's going to take a bit of time to
find the supplies and make it while this
is really just a glorified fetch Quest
you get the sense that mid doesn't want
to see her father the plan was to gather
some of the old members and then
traveled to where the original Hideaway
was but mid said that she would only go
when she's finished and then lie to she
sneaks on a boat after they help her
it's not that she doesn't like her dad
it's just that she doesn't want to feel
sad thinking about him so she's trying
to keep herself busy as much as possible
even though she ended up leaving though
the old crew decides to go anyway as
they wanted to tell Sid that Hugo the
man who destroyed the original Hideaway
is dead Hugo dying is a giant weight
lifted off the shoulders of the Hideaway
as he caused many problems for the group
and while some managed to survive a lot
of them died because of him that's why
Otto also instructed us to tell the
other members before leaving as he sort
of lifts the weight off their shoulders
too killing Hugo was able to put their
comrade souls to rest now that they know
that their killer has been officially
defeated now that that's taken care of
the planets to now destroy the next
Crystal which is the one in the
crystalline dominion and assuming they
succeeded clavel have read all of storm
of the mother crystals The World Isn't
completely Unbound from their power as
the still one in Ash but at least one of
the continents would be free of it as
they arrived though the city is going up
in Flames thanks to the Empire's
dragoons and their leader Dion
terrorizing the town this connects to a
later scene where Dion will meet with
his family and says that he plans to
save his father he believes that his
mind has been corrupted by Annabella and
that's why he's Waging War for the sake
of it he also attempts to put down
Olivier before his father steps in front
of his spear despite being a child
though he doesn't seem too fazed by it
as it seems like Ultima has taken
control of the boy which confirms where
his father's anger came from as a result
Dion lashes out and goes berserk icons
are powerful creatures but require
immense concentration in order to use
them and if too many emotions get in the
way they can go berserk we saw this
happen with benedicta earlier and now
the same is happening to Dion which
explains why he's firing at his own
people despite originally trying to save
them while that happens Clive and Jill
attempt to fight through the havoc and
end up finding Annabella in her quarters
neither is happy to see the other
obviously but while arguing Joshua
crashes into the room thanks to him
being tossed around by Bahamut the
family doesn't exactly have any time to
make amends not that they wanted to
anyway as Bahamut needs to be put down
which is why Clive summons effort and
fights him Bahamut is very strong though
and requires the brothers to combine
their powers in order to defeat them
they literally take the fight into space
itself and even then Dion still requires
lots of damage to fully go down somehow
though even after being hit by dozens of
powerful attacks and averting back to
human form in space Dion has enough
strength to throw his spear one last
time at Olivier killing him for good I
think I'm starting to understand how
Joshua survive Phoenix gate if Dion tank
to blow this hard for the first time
though the brothers finally have time to
talk now they're not being killed by
someone it's good to see the family back
together this scene also shows us that
Ultima was indeed manipulating Dion as
he throws his Spirit who he thinks his
ultimate ends up being Olivier while
grieving over the death of her son
Annabella sees Joshua and kills herself
in front of him I don't believe this to
be the work of Ultima 2 as he isn't
shown in the cutscene so it seems like
she was just struggling to come to terms
of the fact that her son is actually
alive with her dead the group then
leaves and takes Dion with them while
the mother Crystal crumbles in the
background Ultima and retaliation of
this act casts a spell called
primogenesis which not only blackens the
sky but will eventually cause ether
floods across all of Alessia which means
moroccashics will soon arise this is
what Clive will ultimately do battle
with next there's numerous places are
reporting akashic's attacking their
Villages and homes one of them happens
to be canvar a place at the very south
edge of storm which is also where gav
clives Uncle Byron and mid happen to be
located despite his injuries Joshua will
also be joining Jill and Clive on their
Adventure as his assistant yote was told
to meet him there so they get separated
this is also where we learn how Joshua
survived Phoenix gate and that's thanks
to yote and her group called The undying
the undying is basically a shadow
organization within Rosaria whose sole
duty is to protect the heir to the
throne who in this case would be Joshua
according to yote the attackers are not
only an army of akashics but there are
also a few eluder soldiers here which
means Barnabas is planning something we
saw something like this a bit earlier
when trying to kill Hugo's there was an
Army Of Orcs that storm in the castle
despite them not even existing in storm
so at the time it was assumed that
walude had recruited them somehow and
now used them in in their army and this
new attack Alba confirms this suspicion
while the group goes to the city they
end up coming across Harvard again whose
boss name is sleep near despite dying in
this fight Harvard will appear again a
bit later this is because the Lord
harbored here doesn't technically exist
sleep near is the name of Odin's horse
within Norse mythology so it's assumed
that when Barnabas transforms into Odin
Harvard becomes the horse that he rides
into battle somehow it seems like
Barnabas was able to create harbard and
use him to carry out his wishes he also
seems to have an army of them as all
these guards are also called Sleep near
regardless once Clive defeats him the
first time Barnabas will arrive shortly
after in decimate Clive with a single
swing of his blade Jill then decides to
hold him off while they all escape with
Clive which ends up succeeding but at
the cost of Joe being defeated and taken
by Barnabas himself
Clive then eventually wakes up and
decides to take the fight to Barnabas so
they can get Joe back who's currently
being held captive on his ship according
to Barnabas Odin's Blake can cut through
anything I didn't think it was literal
until now as he literally Parts the
entire ocean this causes his Flagship
vessel to fall which is a problem for
Clive as he's still on it thanks to him
rescuing Jill but they seem to be
unharmed at least for now anyway as
Barnabas is here to fight Clive again
who defeats him again Barnabas seems to
be doing this in an attempt to prepare
Clive to be the perfect vessel Clive is
no match for him meaning he isn't ready
to be a part of his plan yet so he's
fighting him in order to assess his
strength either way Clive is injured
which is the least of their problems as
the water seems to be coming back so
Jill attempts to freeze a path out of
there the scene then picks up a few
hours later and the two are both naked
likely because they're drying their
clothes thanks to the water but in the
meantime they talk about each other and
discuss what Barnabas talked about Clive
is battling with his mind and ideals as
he sees the Power of Ifrit as
destructive and feels like he's killed
more people than he saved he questions
whether or not his purpose was to kill
and whether or not what Barnabas wants
is the path he should take it's a very
deep in personal struggle for Clive as
he wants to save everyone but never
thinks about saving himself Jill is
there to comfort him though and decides
to give him the power of shivas that
Clive can do it alone she wants Clive to
understand that he's not alone in this
fight while he does understand that to
an extent he definitely seems to put
others before himself so she figured
that if he's going to keep doing that he
should at least have the power to do so
Clive also recognizes that the sins and
Sorrows he has are a part of him not
just his but everyone's Powers he's
taken he's basically putting the world
on his shoulders and he kind of has to
given he's the only one who can truly
stop Ultima in his plans the two then do
what probably everyone has wanted them
to do at this point which is hug and
embrace each other under the Moonlight
which kind of Harkens back to their last
conversation before Phoenix gate which
was also under the Moonlight as the sun
rises the two wake up and wait for Mid
and the crew to come pick them up from
the shore once found they make their way
back to the Hideaway and come up with a
plan for how to take down the last
mother Crystal which is currently being
guarded by The Fortress of walude the
thing is though is that they just end up
going back to the same Shore that got
picked up from so they travel all the
way back there but now with Gavin Joshua
accompanying Clive Joshua will then
separate from the group as there are
various ruins in Ash thanks to the
blight and he wonders if some of the
specific ruins could give him a clue as
to what the mural was about this is when
Joshua realizes that the beast in the
middle was not some God but rather the
transformation of Ifrit and the Phoenix
the same one they used against Bahamut
earlier blocking their entrance to
walude though is a giant wall of magic
and the only way for them to cross it is
for Barnabas to die so Clive goes alone
to deal with him the dichotomy between
Clive and Barnabas is actually really
interesting is that the embodiments of
two opposite Concepts Barnabas is
someone who obeys unquestioningly and
has no problem submitting themselves to
their fate Clive is the complete
opposite of that as he sees the value in
Free Will and refused to let fate
determine what he is meant to become
this idea of Free Will is the central
reason why he's even doing all this as
he wants to give people the freedom to
choose bears and dominance are used as
tools and are given the same rights as
normal humans so he wants to give them
back their will he wants people to make
decisions because they want to even if
that choice is a bad one it's at least
the choice they made Barnabas and Ultima
would remove the one thing that makes us
human enforce the people of Valencia to
become mindless husks whose only purpose
is to obey orders this is also a major
reason why the two fight as it's a way
to see whose will is stronger Clive of
course comes out on top and defeats
Barnabas but also ends up taking his
power which is something he didn't seem
to want Barnabas during the sea fight
said that the icons are made to be used
by Clive meaning they were all creators
that Clive could take their power Andy
unknowingly did just that is now he has
every single icon under his belt with
Barnabas dead though the wall of magic
has been destroyed and now Joshua and
Clive can destroy the crystal while this
happens we see a cutscene of ultima's
Destruction as hundreds of Akash chicks
have taken over dalmekia Byron and some
of the knights are about to be overrun
before Dion and his Knights come to
defeat them after being taken back to
the Hideaway by Joshua and Clive Diana
would eventually wake up again leave a
note and then leave The Hideaway as he
wanted to revisit the Dominion that he
destroyed the answer to have a habit of
collapsing as that's exactly what he
does the moment he arrives death also
seems to hate him as Dion is saved once
again but this time by a nearby Village
girl I was wondered why the gameplay so
much importance on her and I guess this
is why as she brings Dion back to her
house she is extremely poor but would
rather starve than see someone die so
she offered to help him no matter what
the unsawed this girl's poor living
conditions as well as her drive to help
people and decided to make the most of
it by not only sending Terence to her
home with a large bag of Gill but also
using the second chance to do what's
right which is why he's among the few
people who arrive to help Clive and Josh
once they become cornered thanks to
their help the brothers are able to
survive their recent fight they can make
their way to the crystal except Ultima
is here to ruin the fun as he teleports
the two into an alternate Dimension this
gives them the opportunity to talk to
the brothers about who they are and what
he wants Ultima is not a one of a kind
as he is a part of a previous
civilization that existed eons ago they
were the ones who discovered magic and
were able to harness its power until the
blight came by and destroyed part of
their world the surviving members then
packed up and left to find a new world
to live in which was valessia they
traveled here via their lack of a better
word ship called origin which is where
his brother in our house and is that
giant crystal he resurrects out of the
ground they then decided to create the
mother crystals as a way to harvest vast
amounts of ether and also create
Humanity as a way for them to find a
suitable host to channel this into all
this would create a spell that would
revive ultima's people so Barnabas was
wrong they're not going to create a new
world where they serve them Ultima is
just doing this to save his people he
doesn't care about Humanity furthermore
since he created Humanity Ultima is
literally their God where Ultima failed
though was right after this as he didn't
realize that Humanity would commit the
greatest sin of all at least to him
which was free will he had hoped that
they would have all bait unconditionally
and serve his needs for Life oddly
enough it was actually his fault that
this even happened because for a time he
did serve as their God but eventually
stop listening to The People's cries for
guidance as such they needed to turn
elsewhere and think for themselves so he
was technically the reason Humanity
committed the greatest sin all because
he saw humans as beneath him and thus
decided that their issues are
unimportant to him it's kind of ironic
in that sense as he shunned the people
he needed in order to create the spell
and now his Creations are shutting him
because of it Ultima that attempts to
weaken Clive physically and mentally but
he's unable to which is what caused him
to leave and release origin from the
ground while Clive and Josh would
destroy the last Crystal naturally the
team goes back to hide away to plan the
final attack on Ultima both Clive Joshua
and Dion plan to go there and take the
fight to him with the hope that they win
everyone is worried though as this might
be a one-way trip for them but the trio
knows the consequences and are willing
to sacrifice their life if it means
saving the world once they enter origin
they meet with Ultima in the three face
off against him Clive is wounded in the
attack so Dion tells Joshua to save him
while Dion takes the brunt of altaba's
next attack which kills
very surprising I know but Dion is
actually dead this time he is content
with that though as once again he knew
the risks plus he was able to use this
second chance for good and is now fully
atoned for the sins he committed the
brothers then make it to the inner
chamber where they find Ultimus people
which leads them explaining the second
part of his plan which we already went
over resulting in one of ultima's
Brethren coming out of Joshua's chest
some of ultima's people were Guardians
and the life force of the crystals which
is why we fought a couple of bosses when
we attacked them Ultima wanted us to
destroy the mother crystals that he
could resurrect his people this caused
Joshua to cough up blood and eventually
succumb to his wounds Clive is naturally
torn up over this and tries to talk to
him in his last moments while it happens
Ultima and his people combine to become
Ultimus his people share one
Consciousness so they're able to combine
and become one which is what his new
form is Clive then vows to kill Ultima
as payment for taking his brother in the
two fight in one of the most stunning
Arenas I've ever seen while it is pretty
par for the course as far as boss fights
go one part that was rather interesting
to me was when Clive and Ultima fight
using the icon's abilities in Clive wins
every time he he is without exaggeration
the physical embodiment of the
indomitable human spirit and what it
means to be human he has not only taken
on other people's burdens via their
powers but also put the weight of the
world on his shoulders he truly believes
in what he is fighting for and as a
human he's able to continue that Journey
the most powerful thing we as humans
have is Free Will the ability to make
choices regardless of their outcome is
what makes us human and Clive shows that
not only can you achieve what you want
but that Humanity isn't as fickle as
Ultima thought we as humans can do
anything we set our minds to and we
won't stop until we get what we want
even when the ice cold cruelty of the
world continues to rain down upon us we
get back up and try again and again
until we succeed that's what Clive
represents he's what it means to be
human and next day's Undying Will to
survive and the faith that his friends
and comrades have in him he's able to
defeat Ultima these few moments were the
two fight using the same icons show how
strong Clive's mind is and how dedicated
he is to his own cause everyone believes
in him and he refuses to let them down
whereas Ultima was so wrapped up in his
own desires that he could barely see 10
feet in front of him Ultima only cared
about himself was one to cast out
everyone else in service of that but it
backfired as his own Creations have now
put a stop to him now that Ultima is
dead though Clive decides to fully
complete the plan by removing all magic
and Magic related abilities from the
worlds that everyone is equal and able
to think on their own all the mother
crystals regular crystals icons ethers
and everything else that Ultima created
will be gone forever it would be a
complete reset of the world and while it
would be a rough start it would
ultimately end up being a good idea in
the long run as everyone would be free
Magic has become so important to the
world of Alessia that not only are
people fighting Wars over this stuff but
people are enslaved because of their
magical abilities so removing it would
help free the world it's the exact kind
of world that Sid had envisioned
removing all this also means himself
though which is why he sacrificed his
life for the greater good with the hope
that the world can now finally be at
peace Clive then lies on a beach staring
at the Moon before dying it seems like
Jill was able to sense Clive's death
which absolutely tears her apart but
deep down she knows that his death
wasn't in vain as death has given birth
to a new and much better world the final
scene is a post-credit cutscene of two
boys who look eerily similar to Clive
and Joshua I don't think there's any
relevance to that I just found it to be
a very interesting detail their mother
talks about magic only existing in fairy
tales so it seems like this is a very
long time in the future where magic is
now just a myth to the people of the
world the kids also talk about certain
things from the game like magic the
icons and much more which connects to
what is shown after it seems like the
events of the game have been turned into
a fairy tale called Final Fantasy the
tale seems to be written by Joshua which
is a bit odd seeing as he's dead so this
either means he lived which isn't
exactly out of the realm of possibility
given what we've talked about or someone
else wrote the story using his name
either way the title of the book is
rather convenient as the tale of Final
Fantasy also close out the story of the
latest entry in Final Fantasy
now that it's over though we have to ask
what's next and thanks to this being a
Final Fantasy game there is as likely a
chance that this game gets a sequel as
there is not to get one every game
always seems to end differently 15
didn't get a sequel but got DLC others
are like 13 and got a few sequels like
13-2 and lightning returns and then
there are some that didn't get any Final
Fantasy has always been a bold series
that are always willing to start
something new even if a sequel for a
well-received game would do wonders
given other games end though six team
will likely not get any new content with
the only option being the 15 route where
it's episodic content from my
perspective of another character which
would likely be about Joshua or maybe
the other icons outside of that though I
can't imagine anything else but I do
hope I'm proven wrong as I did
thoroughly enjoy this game's story as
for the rest of the series while we do
have part 2 of the Final Fantasy 7
remake called rebirth dropping at the
end of this year which I will most
definitely be covering in a video like
this and I'm sure 14 is going to
continue to have many updates in the
future due to its increasing popularity
either way that brings us to the end of
the video today as always thank you for
watching check out my other star related
content if you enjoyed this video let me
know what you thought about Final
Fantasy 16 in the comments down below
and thank you to my returning viewers
for coming back to another video take
care everyone
goodbye